it doesn't have a name yet  and the zoo doesn't even know if it's a  boy gorilla or a girl gorillas but this  tiny ape is getting plenty of media  attention even if the mother Shira could  do with paying more attention when she  eats the zoo's experts report that the  new arrival is healthy and strong that's  significant because this species the  western lowland gorilla is threatened  with extinction it is extremely  important to breed endangered animals in  zoos because we need a big population to  make sure that we don't have any  inbreeding problems for example and one  must say that gorillas in the wild are  very much endangered of course Shira and  her offspring know little of genetic  diversity but she does seem to realize  that it's best to leave the paparazzi  wanting more